sie sind mehr als nur gigantische brücke
sie sind meilensteine der baukunst jeder
von ihnen setzte in ihrer zeit ein
technologisches ausrufezeichen
sie gehören zu den spektakulärsten
bauwerken der welt und man kann selbst
mit dem auto darüber fahren täglich
rollen hunderttausende fahrzeuge
übersehen mit darunter tonnen schweren
lkw das macht ihre wartung enorm
aufwendig sie ist gigantisch und steckt
voller details die regelmäßig
kontrolliert
jeden tag werden diese brücken vom
verkehr durchgerüttelt viele stehen im
gebirge andere führen übers wasser die
arbeitsbedingungen für die wartungs
teams sind hat
schon sie zu planen ist eine
herausforderung und erst recht sie zu
bauen es hieß die sind verrückt dass wir
zusammen sind multi millionen projekte
die ingenieure und bauunternehmer nicht
selten an den rand der verzweiflung
treiben
die gigantischen konstruktionen
verschieden die grenzen des machbaren
und das fordert manchmal seinen preis
aber wenn sie schließlich fertig sind
und man mit dem auto über sie hinweg
galt ist das ein erhebendes gefühl
für mich ist das die schönste brücke der
welt
sie sind die atemberaubendsten bauwerke
die man mit dem auto befahren kann hier
sind die geheimnisse hinter der
konstruktion ihr spektakulärer bau und
die täglichen herausforderungen bei
ihrer wartung
gigantische konstruktion die
spektakulärsten auto brücken der welt
[Musik]
majestätisch
gigantisch
schwindelerregend was heutzutage möglich
ist ist schier unglaublich
ohne einige entscheidende meilensteine
in der geschichte des autobaus wären
solche konstruktion völlig undenkbar
der erste innovationsschub kommt in den
dreißiger jahren des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts erstmals werden brücken für
autos und schwere lastwagen gebraucht in
den sechziger und siebziger jahren dann
der nächste große sprung
gezwungenermaßen in dieser zeit schießen
die zahlen der neu zugelassenen autos in
die höhe
möchte ich ständige technische
weiterentwicklung im brückenbau wird es
möglich immer höher länger und trag
kräftiger zu bauen
ein erster meilenstein auf dem weg zur
immer gigantischeren brücken die
europabrücke in den österreichischen
alpen
1963 zu ihrer fertigstellung ist sie die
höchste brücke europas ihre
brückenpfeiler sind damals die höchsten
der welt die europabrücke wurde 1963
eröffnet die längste spanne zwischen
zwei pfeilern beträgt 198 meter sie
liegt nördlich von innsbruck
[Musik]
über 13 millionen fahrzeuge überqueren
die autobahnbrücke jedes jahr zwei
millionen davon sind lkw
mit jeweils bis zu 40 tonnen gewicht
machen sie einen großteil der belastung
aus
[Musik]
die europabrücke ist das herzstück der
brennerautobahn der transitstrecke über
die alpen der wichtigsten nord süd
verbindung europas
seit über 50 jahren überspannt die 190
meter hohe brücke dieses tal vor ihrem
bau war der einzige weg auf den
brennerpass diese bundesstraße
endlos wendet sie sich den steilen berg
hinauf
seit 1963 führt die reise über fünf
gigantische stahl betonpfeiler
den brücken kern bildet ein hohlkörper
aus stahl er trägt die fahrbahn wegen
der enormen spannweite kann schon die
kleinste materialermüdung zur
katastrophe führen die brücke muss
deswegen regelmäßig geprüft und gewartet
werden
der starke verkehr ist eine große
belastung für die konstruktion ein
zusätzliches problem die brücke liegt in
einer schneise der fallwind von den
bergen kann geschwindigkeiten von bis zu
150 kilometern pro stunde erreichen
orkanstärke
[Musik]
und ausgerechnet heute bei starkem wind
steht eine hauptleitung an
brücken prüfer peter auch schön und sein
kollege dominik reithner wollen sich
über die brüstung wagen mit diesem
speziellen kran
ob der starke wind einer prüfung heute
überhaupt zulässt ist allerdings
fraglich
wenn der wind zu stark ist wird es zu
gefährlich noch steht das brücken
inspektions gerät im windschatten am
anfang der brücke um wirklich prüfen zu
können müssen die beiden mit dem gerät
viel wasser raus über die schlucht auch
schön und leitner verschaffen sich am
ersten betonpfeiler einen eindruck von
den bedingungen
seit der letzten inspektion hat der
beton unter der witterung stark gelitten
leitner und auch schul wollen nun wissen
wie schwer es den ställen hole baukasten
erwischt hat
die beiden kontrolleure wagen sich zu
fuß zur mitte der brücke hier wird
erfüllen der typische und oft typische
wind der alpen besonders stark
[Musik]
schäfer vom gerät her da gibt es keine
gewisse funktionen funktionieren dann
gar nicht mehr wenn zu großem instanzen
sind und dann nicht mal eingeschränkten
muss man halt
so wie heute der starke wind lässt die
inspektion der brücke nicht zu wegen der
permanenten belastung sind regelmäßige
überprüfungen der fahrbahn unterseite
aber unerlässlich
starker böiger wind extrem viel verkehr
tonnen schwere lkw und einer brücke die
weit über 50 jahre alt ist für den
heutigen europabrücke chefinspektor
martin kirchmaier ist das bauwerk ein
kleines wunder
die fast 150 meter hohen betonpfeiler
sind im innenhof genau wie der
aufliegende stahl hohen kasten alles ist
aerodynamik optimiert die brücke gehört
zu den ersten bauwerken deren statik im
windkanal getestet wurde um zu starke
schwingungen und überlastungen zu
vermeiden
so kann die europabrücke heute dem im
vergleich zu damals zehnfachen
verkehrsaufkommen standhalten
bis zum baubeginn 1959 waren weltweit
noch nie so hohe betonpfeiler errichtet
worden und diese sollten nun
ausgerechnet in den alpen gebaut werden
die ingenieure standen vor einer
mammutaufgabe
und auch die bedingungen für die
arbeiter waren hart starker wind große
kälte und das alles im hochgebirge
insgesamt starben beim bau der
brennerautobahn 22 menschen
zwei wochen nach dem gescheiterten
inspektions versuch heute wollen die
männer den nächsten anlauf wagen
vorausgesetzt das wetter spielt endlich
mit wie immer läuft der verkehr auf der
brücke weiter eine der
hauptverkehrsadern europas komplett zu
sperren
undenkbar für die inspektion kann nur
die rechte fahrbahn geschlossen werden
die männer bringen dass brücken
inspektions gerät in stellung
ob die inspekteure heute die fahrbahn
unterseite kontrollieren können wird
sich erst herausstellen wenn sie das
gerät in die mitte der brücke gefahren
haben
mehrere male musste die inspektion in
den letzten tagen wegen zu hoher
windgeschwindigkeiten verschoben werden
doch für heute sind auch schön und
leitner optimistisch
10 km h
zentral warum jetzt gemessen was ich da
endlich kann es losgehen
190 meter über dem talgrund
auch schön und leitner steigen ab zu
einem der spektakulärsten arbeitsplätze
europas höhenangst sollte man hier
allerdings nicht haben
die aufgabe der beiden inspekteure
schäden dokumentieren und den zeitrahmen
für die instandsetzung festlegen
hat den konstanzer piste zurück
vor über 30 jahren wurde die
stahlkonstruktion
verbreitert an den nahtstellen sitzt sie
besonders gern rost an
auch schön hält jeden rost schaden genau
fest
überall auf dem haupt träger finden die
beiden rost grund zur sorge
so machen wir uns einfach keine sehe ich
sehr gut beobachtet und wir haben auch
natürlich auch laut in den stand
haltungs arbeiten dass man immer einen
guten zustand
fazit der haupt inspektion ist auf die
roststellen entdecken die beiden keine
schäden am hohen kasten der europabrücke
die
zukunft einer der hauptverkehrsadern
europas und einer der spektakulärsten
autobahnbrücken der welt ist weiterhin
gesichert
die nächste spektakuläre brücke ist
nicht weit weg in der schweiz
[Musik]
gegen ende der siebziger jahre erreicht
die ingenieurskunst des brückenbaus die
nächste entwicklungsstufe weg von der
reinen funktion hin zum aufregenden
design die ganter brücke im
schweizerischen kanton wallis ist dafür
ein eindrucksvolles beispiel ist ohne
zweifel einer der spektakulärsten auto
brücken der welt umgeben von 4000 meter
hohen bergen
[Musik]
die ganze brücke ist seit 1980 in
betrieb maximale spannweite
174 meter sie gehört zur simplen pass
straße im süden der schweiz
vor dem bau der brücke musste sich der
verkehr die steilen hänge herab und
wieder hinauf schlängelt immer wieder
kam es zu steinschlägen und tödlichen
unfällen
heute hat die reise durch das tal ihren
schrecken verloren die alte brücke hat
lange ausgedient in der schweiz gibt es
viele brücken aber die ganze brücke
stellt sie alle in den schatten
alle fünf jahre steht die revision der
gesamten brücke an
[Musik]
bauingenieur thomas werlen und sein
kollege pierluigi tami kennen die brücke
gut und wissen worauf sie achten müssen
zuerst gehen sie ins herz der
konstruktion ins innere der brücke sie
sind jetzt direkt unterhalb der fahrbahn
werlen und ariane dringen in die mitte
des stahlbeton hole kastens vor zu einer
stelle die ihn schon vor fünf jahren bei
der letzten inspektion aufgefallen ist
[Musik]
wenn man grad
die stahl verstärkung innerhalb des
betons ist anfällig für korrosion die
inspekteure wollen sicherstellen dass
keine gefahr droht
thomas werlen ist erleichtert erst vor
zehn jahren haben die schweizer die
brücke aufwendig saniert für ihn ist
diese brücke weit mehr als nur ein weg
von a nach b
[Musik]
eine wirklich konstruieren kann oder
daran beteiligt ist er will da sein auch
mit stolz und diese infektion sind so
da bei solchen objekten ist es so wie
ein museumsbesuch mit technik geschichte
verbunden man sieht was möglich ist was
alles
die bauarbeiten beginnen im jahr
1976 die große herausforderung für die
konstrukteure die pfeiler die auf der
nordseite des talboden stehen denn er
ist der hang nicht fest er kriecht
langsam nach unten bis zu einem
zentimeter pro jahr trotzdem sollen die
pfeiler dauerhaft 18.500 kubikmeter
beton und 2000 tonnen stahl tragen
die ingenieure stehen vor einem problem
wie sollen sie diesen gigantischen fast
100 meter hohen pfeiler in einem krieg
an verankern
professor christian man nimmt die
herausforderung an er ist der
renommierteste brückenbauer der schweiz
die ganter brücke sollen sein
meisterstück werden
auf der einen seite ist es
so oft haben sie so genau hänge das sind
zu den modernen und weiß ich was die
mit einem material das ein bisschen
krieg und da kann man sich dort
umfassende
lösung er versenkt die pfeiler in
speziell entwickelten schächten die
langsam mit dem hahn mit wandern die
pfeiler selbst bleiben auf speziellen
gleitlagern stabil die auf dem
rutschenden hang nachjustiert werden
können in überbau versteift er mit
einbetonierten kabel zügen flexible
verankerung steifer über bauch eine
geniale kombination
wenn die ganze sache versuchen werden
muss dann sollte sie
[Musik]
die steif sein wobei eine lücke die nur
ankommt ganz feine träger hat es eben
nicht so steif und diese versteifungen
die fundamente sind breiter als die
pfeiler und erlauben handbewegungen von
bis zu 60 zentimetern
die kontrolle der lager auf denen die
pfeiler ruhen einer der wichtigsten
teile der inspektion
[Musik]
hier
hast du eigentlich zwei bewegungen da
siehst du jetzt jetzt haben wir momentan
17 zentimeter in eine richtung aus der
opposition heraus und 15 diese richtung
von 1980 war das sicher
eine sensationelle leistung
[Musik]
die fundamente sind stark der witterung
ausgesetzt
berlin und sajani stoßen auf schäden die
erheblich größer sind als die im inneren
der brücke
teilweise schon jedes jahr zwei
zentimeter das heißt überdeckung ist
auch schon nicht mehr gewährleistet
nicht mehr wollen und das auf 1500
metern höhe mit eis schnee und salz und
wenn wir das nicht machen würden einfach
nur zu warten bis irgendein schaden
soweit da ist dann wird wird taillierung
vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr imstande
die speziellen fundamente sind die
kritischen punkte der ganter brücke sie
tragen den hauptteil ihres eigenen
gewichts und der verkehrsbelastung
die lebensdauer eines bauwerks hängt von
vielen faktoren ab hier oben in den
alpen ist die witterung ein problem
an einigen stellen ist die schicht
abgeplatzt die den beton vor dem
streusalz gegen das eis auf der brücke
schützen soll diese stellen müssen auf
jeden fall ausgebessert werden
[Musik]
an der beton verschalung der
stabilisierenden kabelstränge hat man
auf die teure schutzschicht verzichtet
ob sich das jetzt recht
auf der ganzen oberfläche zu fein
verteilte netzartige risse und die waren
jetzt das ist es hier die werden bei der
alten inspektion auch schon vorhanden
nach zwei tagen inspektion hat thomas
werlen einen ersten eindruck vom zustand
der canter brücke
wir haben normale
abnutzungserscheinungen wie die halb
vollkommen aber durch das
inspektionssystem wo man alle fünf jahre
die kontrollen wurde gemacht kann jetzt
ja auch nicht zu großem schaden kommen
weil es kann direkt bevor das etwas
schlimmeres wird der schaden aufgenommen
und kann behoben werden das wäre ja
fahrlässig wenn man einfach nur 30 jahre
lang nichts gemacht und dann wollt
schaut kommt es noch hält
[Musik]
die ganze brücke ein herausragendes
bauwerk ein monument schweizer
ingenieurs kunst und ein eindrucksvolles
beispiel für eine gelungene verbindung
von form und funktion in gigantischen
maßstab aber
auf der anderen seite des atlantik
verschiedenen die brücken konstrukteure
nur wenig später die grenzen des
machbaren noch ein stück weiter die
sunshine skyway bridge in florida gehört
bis heute zu den längsten schräg sei
betonbrücken der welt
die sunshine skyway bridge wurde 1987
eröffnet und kostete mehr als 660
millionen dollar
sie überspannt die tampa bay von saint
petersburg nach theresia mit seinem
hellen gelb repräsentiert der sunshine
skyway den sunshine state florida
[Musik]
sechs uhr morgens die erste wartungs
crew macht sich auf den weg
wegen der starken belastungen durch
salzwasser starken wind und hohe
temperaturen arbeiten täglich mehrere
cruz an der gigantischen brücke
dieses team kontrolliert die riesigen
brückenpfeiler von unten und parallel
dazu gibt es auch oben auf der brücke
einiges zu tun
denn mal ins und jeff player besprechen
die letzten details für ihren heutigen
einsatz oben auf dem sun shines kmu
dann machen sie sich auf den weg ihr
wartungsauftrag führt sie in die mitte
der brücke war damit auf die vierspurige
autobahn
zwischen sind petersburg und terrasse
überqueren täglich mehr als 50.000
fahrzeuge die brücke
wir haben 24 stunden sieben tage die
woche rufbereitschaft unfällen und
solche sachen das sind lange tage und
nächte man muss immer auf alles gefasst
sein morgens und seine crew warten die
brücke täglich nur so bleibt die
sicherheit der sunshine skyway bridge
gewährleistet im offenen meer steht an
diesem morgen muss man es während der
rushhour zum einsatzort wir müssen immer
erst durch den verkehr durch der mitte
der brücke zu tun haben oder von hier
aus ins innere
im team zu arbeiten gibt sicherheit
ihrer passt auf jeden auf in der job ist
gefährlich trotz des tempolimits von
rund 100 kilometern pro stunde ist der
verkehr auf der brücke unberechenbar es
gibt keine ausweichmöglichkeiten rechts
und links ist wasser
du musst einfach immer gut aufpassen
dann ist es nicht so schlimm wenn wir
erst mal überlegen bevor du was macht
den überblick behalten
um zu den schrägsten zu kommen müssen
die arbeiter mitten im berufsverkehr auf
der autobahn eine lücke finden und das
kann auch mal dauern
eines der hauptprobleme der sunshine
skyway brücke die korrosion des im beton
verbauten stahls malens und seinen crew
mussten schon oft teile renovieren
verstärken und austauschen
[Musik]
eine solche brücke hat auch wenn sie
riesig ist viele kleine teile die
ständig gewartet und kontrolliert wer
immer sich
die männer arbeiten permanent an der
brücke das ist notwendig wegen der stark
salzhaltigen luft und das ist längst
nicht die einzige gefahr im golf von
mexiko
warnendes beispiel die vorgänger brücke
die an fast der gleichen stelle stand
sie wurde 1980 von einem schiff gerammt
366 meter brücke fallen ins meer mit ihr
sechs autos und ein greyhound bus
35 menschen ertranken in der tampa bay
noch heute erinnern die alten enden der
brücke an das unglück
die neue sunshine skyway brett wird
schon sieben jahre nach dem unglück
fertiggestellt die pfeiler auf denen die
brücke ruht werden von beiden seiten
durch kleine künstliche inseln vom
schiffsverkehr
[Musik]
abgeschlossen hat seine lehren aus der
vergangenheit gezogen
wir wollten ganz sicher gehen dass so
etwas nicht nochmal passiert deswegen
sind die pfeiler bei der neuen brücke
viel besser geschützt
die künstlichen inseln um sie herum
verhindern dass ein schiff mit ihnen
kollidieren kann
und die hauptpfeiler sind zusätzlich von
größeren inseln aus großen felsbrocken
geben so dass sie niemals von einem
schiff gerammt werden können
die
stahlkonstruktion ermöglicht eine
breitere schiffspassage und eine bessere
verteilung der kräfte auch bei hohem
seegang starken winden und hurricanes
die brücke kann wegen der kleinen
vorgelagerten inseln nicht mehr geräumt
werden diese sind tief im meeresboden
der tampa bay verankerte röhren aus
stahl gefüllt mit grobem kies
[Musik]
die bedingungen für die arbeiter waren
hat
unter wasser als die stahlröhren im
meeresboden verankert werden und dann
hoch über dem wasser als die brücken
teile miteinander verbunden wurden dass
sie sich schließlich in der mitte trafen
sicherheit hatte für die ingenieure
oberste priorität das sieht man daran
wie die brücke konstruiert ist sie
besteht aus beton stahl kabel
stabilisieren zusätzlich die längsten
stützweite
durch die runden inseln rings um die
pfeiler wird ein schiff bei einer
eventuellen kollision zur seite
abgelenkt so dass nicht die ganze wucht
des aufpralls den pfeiler trifft
40 kleinere vorgelagerte inseln schützen
die brücke zusätzlich vor schiffen die
sie rammen könnten nach den berechnungen
der ingenieure kann die brücke
kollisionen mit schiffen bis zu
87.000 tonnen überstehen trotz ihrer
raffinierten konstruktion muss die sun
shines cambridge im golf von mexiko
ständig gewartet und erneuert werden
theron malens und seine kollegen wissen
dass sie so mit ihrer arbeit nie fertig
sein werden trotzdem mag marines seinen
job
[Musik]
was mir in meinem job als
wartungsarbeiter auf der brücke so
gefällt ist dass sich immer draußen
fast in der natur
und so geht ein tag mit wartungsarbeiten
ober und unterhalb einer der
spektakulärsten brücken der welt zu ende
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit einer besonders
langen brücke und das ist nicht nur so
dahergesagt diese brücke ist wirklich
lang lang genug um zwei länder
miteinander zu verbinden die
öresundbrücke ist die längste brücke
europas
[Musik]
seit 2000 ist die öresund brücke in
betrieb kostenpunkt rund eine milliarde
euro
sie verbindet die dänische hauptstadt
kopenhagen mit malmö in schweden
sie ist eines der größten
infrastrukturprojekte
europas
ihr bau auf see war ein megaprojekt dass
ingenieure und technologie an ihre
grenzen brachte
es ist sieben uhr morgens dienstbeginn
für christian norm und den technischen
direktor der brücke sein arbeitstag
beginnt fast immer in der
überwachungszentrale
keine brücke wird so streng elektronisch
kontrolliert wie die höhere summe brücke
und der aufwand hat gute gründe die
höhere sind brücke ist eine kombinierte
straßen und eisenbahn brücke und darf
sich nur in ganz bestimmten grenzen
verformen
dazu werden verkehrslasten und
wetterdaten ständig gemessen und
bewertet alles wird mit kameras
überwacht um mögliche gefahren und
unfälle sofort erkennen zu können
[Musik]
die höhere und brücke ist die längste
schrägseilbrücke der welt für
kombinierten straßen und
eisenbahnverkehr insgesamt 30.000
sensoren und 256 kameras sammeln nicht
nur daten zum verkehrsaufkommen und zum
wetter sondern messen und beobachten
auch die schwingungen der stahlseile
christian normans kennt das system und
entdeckt eine beunruhigende warnmeldung
ein sensor in einem der tunnel die zur
brücke führen meldet einen fehler im
lüftungssystem
wenn das system nicht funktioniert
können wir die temperatur nicht konstant
halten in dem gebäude und wenn die
temperatur steigt könnte das elektrische
system reis laufen und das könnte zu
noch größeren problemen
das schlimmste wäre ein ausfall der
belüftung
christian norm und macht sich sofort auf
den weg um sich das problem vor ort
anzusehen an einem tag wie heute ist das
wartungsteam ohnehin in
alarmbereitschaft bei schlechtem wetter
beobachten die verantwortlichen die
situation rund um die brücke ganz genau
nimmt der wind zu und ein sturm zieht
auf kann es sogar sein dass sie die
brücke vorübergehend schließen müssen
christian ist dem gut gesicherten
elektronischen herz der öresund brücke
angekommen hier läuft die gesamte
elektrotechnik zusammen eine der
wichtigsten komponenten der über eine
milliarde euro teuren brücke die
öresundbrücke ist eine der am besten
überwachten brücken der welt hier laufen
unzählige kilometer kabel und leitungen
zusammen die fehlersuche gleicht der
suche nach einer nadel im heuhaufen
ich muss testen ob hier ein signal an
liegt
das signal sagt es ist offen also muss
ich versuchen es zu justieren
diesmal findet christian den fehler im
kühlungs und lüftungssystem der tunnel
ungewöhnlich schnell
aus signal
und jetzt ist es an
das bedeutet dass wir einen fehler
weniger an die insgesamt fast acht
kilometer lange brücke macht es möglich
direkt von dänemark nach schweden zu
fahren täglich nutzen 19.000 fahrzeuge
und 200 züge die brücke aber die
gigantische brücke zu bauen war eine
enorme herausforderung
so musste eine vier kilometer lange
künstliche insel im meer aufgeschüttet
werden hier verschwindet die dänische
seite der brücke in einem tunnel damit
die einflugschneise des kopenhagener
flughafen nicht durch brückenelemente
blockiert wird ein weiteres problem die
durchfahrtshöhe unter der brücke soll 57
meter betragen dafür müssen gigantische
pfeiler mit einer gesamthöhe von 203
metern im meeresboden verankert werden
bauleiter lars petersen musste am anfang
mit vielen widerständen kämpfen
wir anfingen waren alle pessimistisch
einige waren besorgt in bezug auf die
wirtschaftlichkeit andere wegen des
zeitplans und der umwelt aber es stellte
sich heraus dass das hässliche entlein
in jeder hinsicht ein wunderschöner
schwan wurde
[Musik]
die strategie von lars petersen und
seinem team sie lassen fast alles an
land fertigen und dann mit schwimmkränen
aufs meer transportieren dort wird alles
dann nur noch zusammengesetzt der plan
geht auf die knapp kalkulierte bauzeit
von viereinhalb jahren wird sogar
unterschritten
es gab viel protest sogar noch während
des baus aber es stellte sich heraus
dass es lösungen gab für jedes problem
für mich für mich ist die öresundbrücke
etwas ganz besonderes für mich ist sie
die schönste brücke der welt
aber die über 7,8 kilometer lange brücke
ist extrem betreuungs intensiv christian
normandie ist schon auf dem weg zu
seinem nächsten problem
wir haben ein problem auf der
nordwestbahn ohne mit dem warnlicht für
flugzeuge wir müssen da kurz anhalten
und gucken was los ist weil es nicht
blinkt das muss funktionieren
und zwar immer
die höhere sind brücke liegt nur fünf
kilometer entfernt von kopenhagen der
flughafen der flugverkehr darf unter
keinen umständen gefährdet werden das
ist auch der grund dafür dass ein
brücken ende im tunnel verschwinden
musste
aber das aktuelle problem liegt weit
über dem meer in 200 metern höhe ist auf
der hauptbühne eine warnleuchte für
flugzeuge in der einflugschneise nach
kopenhagen ausgefallen christian fährt
mit dem fahrstuhl innerhalb der brille
zum höchsten punkt der brücke
eigentlich sollten hier nicht nur die
linke und die mittlere warnleuchte
blinken sondern auch die rechte doch die
ist offenbar defekt
zum glück stellt sich heraus dass eine
schutzhaltung die leuchte vorübergehend
abgeschaltet hat christian kann den
fehler sofort beheben wieder eine
fehlermeldung weniger
[Musik]
ja wunderbar jetzt funktioniert es
wieder
und wenn man schon oben ist warum nicht
auch mal für einen moment die
atemberaubende aussicht genießen
tja so ist die arbeit seit ich hier
angefangen habe alles ist so fantastisch
und gigantisch alle die hier arbeiten
sind teil das ist der beste job
überhaupt
die brücke zwischen kopenhagen und malmö
eine der wichtigsten
verkehrsverbindungen im norden europas
und eine der spektakulärsten auto
brücken der welt
doch der neueste meilenstein im otto
brückenbau steht ganz im westen europas
wieder ist es eine schräg sein konstrukt
aber eine wie keine zweite auf der welt
die brücke von mio in frankreich hat den
höchsten brückenpfeiler weltweit
schon bei ihrem bau wurden rekorde
gebrochen und grenzen gesprengt
die wartung ist jeden tag ein abenteuer
die brücke von mio verändert die
landkarte von europa sie ist aktuell der
gipfel im autobahnbrücken
[Musik]
sie wurde 2004 eröffnet die längste
spanne zwischen zwei pfeilern beträgt
342 meter
sie liegt in südfrankreich
und sie ist eine brücke der superlative
er baut um hurricanes und erdbeben zu
widerstehen sie repräsentiert den
aktuellen stand der technik was
schrägseilbrücke angeht
7 teiler erheben die fahrbahn über das
tal feiner so hoch wie wolkenkratzer
die pylone aus stahl statt stahl beton
reduzieren die gesamtlast sie
ermöglichen es so mit einem minimum an
schräg seilen auszukommen die die
brücken lastverteilung
in ihrer bis ins letzte detail
ausgefeilten konstruktion stecken die
erfahrungen aus jahrhunderten des
brückenbaus
mit ihren spektakulären ausmaßen ist sie
ein meisterstück der ingenieurskunst
zwölf jahre lang diskutierten die
franzosen über die optimale lösung
hinsichtlich ästhetik und
praktikabilität
[Musik]
theodorou taffen von 70 die kürzeste
verbindung zwischen paris und barcelona
eine der hauptverkehrsadern europas der
landschaftlich spektakulärste teil der
autobahn führt über das tantal
früher ging es nur über serpentinen und
unzählige kehren durch das tal häufige
staus waren die folge bis zu zwei
stunden dauerte die fahrt
[Musik]
die lösung die brücke von new einer
straße durch die luft jetzt fahren die
autos in zehn minuten über das tal
2004 wird die brücke endlich eröffnet
[Musik]
an jedem pylon sind 22 seile verankert
11 auf jeder seite im inneren besteht
jedes aus einzelnen stahlkabel der
höchste lohn misst 343 meter vom tal
boden bis zur spitze der eiffelturm ist
deutlich kleiner
[Musik]
hohe pylone große spannweiten bei dieser
autobahnbrücke ist nicht nur die
konstruktion einer herausforderung
sondern auch die regelmäßige wartung
[Musik]
sieben uhr morgens wartungs chef terry
wey satt und sein team starten in den
arbeitstag sie bereiten sich auf einen
einsatz in extremer höhe vor es gibt
probleme mit der beleuchtung der brücke
[Musik]
theorien france war kannst du bisher
kommen wir haben ein problem auf der
spitze vom p2 ein flugzeug waren nicht
muss ausgetauscht werden ausgerechnet an
der spitze des höchsten pylons
so hast du alles dabei was wir brauchen
die lampe das werkzeug wir müssen rauf
auf den p2 die lampe geht nicht die
müssen wir auswechseln
persönlich wird die lampe im höchsten
der sieben teile austauschen
direkt unter der fahrbahn führt ein
fußweg durch das innere der brücke
während oben die autos über den asphalt
rauschen laufen die techniker direkt
unter der fahrbahn zum feiern
es ist ein langer weg
dann müssen die beiden ja noch fast 100
meter bis zur spitze hochklettern
hier müssen wir jetzt drauf auf den
clown nummer zwei das ist schon ziemlich
anstrengend schließlich geht das 87
meter hoch
es beginnt der lange und beschwerliche
aufstieg
87 metern nur über leitern die männer
müssen immer zu zweit hochklettern falls
ein unfall passiert der pfeiler ist
sechseckig und reicht vom talboden aus
90 meter in die höhe dann verzweigte
sich in zwei pfeiler diese form
wiederholt sich umgedreht über der
fahrbahn bis zur spitze
das problem der enormen höhe der brücke
spätestens wenn die nacht hereinbricht
und es dunkel wird droht gefahr
[Musik]
denn der nächste flughafen rollis masia
ist nur 60 kilometer von der brücke
entfernt
startende und landende flugzeuge müssen
die brücke sehen können
deshalb setzen ganz oben auf den
pfeilern flugzeug warnlichter wenn
dieser lampen ausfallen kann es
gefährlich werden
[Musik]
damit das auf keinen fall passiert
tauscht das wartungsteam der brücke die
birnen regelmäßig aus nicht erst wenn
sie ausgefallen sind sondern schon dann
wenn sich die laufzeit dem ende neigt
wie satin sein kollege haben es fast
geschafft
seit einer halben stunde kämpfen sie
sich den pfeiler hoch und heute ist
ausgerechnet das warnlicht auf p2 dem
höchsten pylon dran
oben angekommen muss weg nach draußen
eine kleine plattform in
schwindelerregenden 343 metern höhe hier
sitzt das flugzeug war nicht bei dem die
beiden techniker heute die birne
auswechseln müssen
[Musik]
es ist immer noch ein ganz besonderes
gefühl wenn man oben auf dem pylon ist
die aussicht ist einzigartig für
base hat und seine kollegen beginnt der
heikelste teil der arbeit hier oben muss
jeder handgriff sitzen selbst der
kleinste fehler könnte fatal sein alles
was hier herunter fällt landet als
gefährliches geschoss auf der fahrbahn
wir sind immer sehr konzentriert bei der
arbeit wir müssen extrem aufpassen dass
uns nichts vor unterfeld
oben auf der plattform können im sturm
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 200
kilometern in der stunde herrschen und
wenn eine lampe defekt ist müssen die
männer trotzdem auf
[Musik]
schon der bau der brücke war ein
riesiges abenteuer
brücken leiter emanuel car show erinnert
sich noch sehr gut an den permanenten
zeitdruck
[Musik]
hier mussten die brücke innerhalb von
drei jahren bauen wir haben die
fahrbahnen von beiden seiten aufeinander
zu geschoben das war sehr aufwendig und
kompliziert wir haben dafür spezielle
gps systeme verwendet zum ersten mal im
brückenbau überhaupt
die herausforderung die fahrbahnen von
beiden seiten des tals auf die pfeile zu
schieben meter für meter schoben
hydraulische systeme die beiden enden
vorwärts und das in bis zu 245 metern
höhe
[Musik]
die fahrbahnen haben zum teil wellen
geschlagen
die leute die nicht vom fach waren haben
das gesehen und gesagt die sind doch
verrückt da stürzt 1
500 männer sind drei jahre lang rund um
die uhr im einsatz und schaffen es
tatsächlich
21.000 tonnen stahl und 200 6000 tonnen
beton kilometer lang durch die luft
zuführen
am 14 dezember 2004 ist es geschafft ein
historischer tag
aber die arbeit an der brücke ist nie zu
ende jeden tag ist ein vierköpfiges team
im einsatz um sie instand zu halten
auch auf dem höchsten brückenpfeiler der
welt
wie satt und seine kollegen haben das
flugzeug war nicht inzwischen
auseinandergenommen jetzt können sie die
birne wechseln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die spektakuläre aussicht entschädigt
sie für den stress
wenn wir es dann geschafft haben macht
das schon spaß bei dem blick vergisst
man die anstrengung oder francois
der aufstieg ist immer etwas hart aber
oben ist es einfach nur schön
[Musik]
es ist wohl einer der spektakulärsten
arbeitsplätze die es gibt der höchste
brückenpfeiler der welt auf der brücke
von bio